oh you you saying that has it been a
hard life
oh road yeah it's been a hard life
but i don't believe i'd have it no other
way
all right markham ray yeah mark and ray
uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally out here in manchester
and you uh grew up with both your both
your parents
well yeah this group i grew up
one-fourth kids around
one of the poorest yeah tell me about
your your childhood
well my childhood i was stumped
i was beat by a man that was one of the
best
persons there was and
other than that it's more mental abuse
and physical abuse and you know what to
do with
what kind of stuff you go through
well your brain's being split out with
everything you can stomped in the
stomach
equipped with uh cords
switches and everything else is your dad
huh this is your dad yeah
and i've been on my own ever since i was
eight years old
eight years old yeah where'd you leave
at eight because it was a couple of
stand it no more
and where'd you go at eight i went to my
grandmother's out here
stayed with her up until i was about 20
and
i left then i met a girl named mary
married a girl named mary harris she was
15 years old we had two kids
and uh in 1988 we got divorced
and she i still love her more day than i
did first day we married
did you raise your kids well
i went um one of them
her mother and dad raised because we was
too young you know what i'm saying
but we we couldn't get a chance to raise
a kid
you know what i'm saying and then our
baby boy
i went and got him a brother called me
one night and he told me he said ray
don't come get this kid said i'm gonna
take him to social services so i went
the next day got him brought him home i
laid him down beside my mother
he was here up to he got with
another one with his woman what kind of
jobs have you had
uh tobacco work
roofing um
lord i couldn't tell y'all what kind of
what i've had uh
20 some here on the garbage route and
uh i've owned one home
that was stole stolen right out from
under me by
by a trailer company along with another
friend of mine
her therapy their trailer was taken
right out none of them it never was even
delivered they got their money but
and then there was a guy named my boy
got sick one month and uh
i got behind on a trailer payment guy
told me he said ray
he said uh send me a double payment
first month everything be fine
i sent a double payment at the first uh
uh the first of the following month
a week later i was called told me to get
out of the trailer
so you grew up here in manchester
kentucky this is
you know deep in appalachia very poor
right
uh it's one of the poorest parts of
kentucky even exactly
so i mean that means it's the poorest
part of the country probably
what's it like growing up here you love
appalachia i love manchester more than
anything in the world
it's just a hard year there's no work to
do
uh and uh i've been enjoy out of jail
more times than you could count
for uh drug use but i never was caught
with no drugs
and things like that but it's uh ain't
no wonder there's some many
uh fighting arguing stealing and all
that stuff there's no work for people to
do
i mean son i know some of the smartest
people they are around smarter than
college students
like these right down your t store right
down here some best people you'll ever
meet
some of the smartest people they're
builders uh
of everything and there's just no work
around here for them today
yeah that's that's the problem here so
remote so rural
yeah that there's there are no factories
there's no jobs here there's no nothing
ain't nothing here yeah what the what
kind of schooling did you get
eighth grade that's right i dropped out
when i was 15 years old
but you can read and write yeah yeah
and what do you do for fun here what do
you do for enjoyment
well i leave about to crack a daylight
after losing everything i had
right there almost 34 000
worth of stuff that like most people go
to a furniture store and pay two or
three hundred dollars for
i'd wind up paying for mine by the month
eighteen twenty four months
i had almost thirty four thousand dollar
worth of stuff right right there in that
trailer plus my home too
so that trailer is empty and now you
live in this well no it ain't empty it's
got my things sitting in it
but there's so many snakes crawling
around here and things
that it just i killed a copyrighted
column right out of that wall the other
day
and i stay on the road most time
i come here my mom's i lay down and i go
to sleep i'm back up the next morning
i'm on the road again i built my own
bike
i got a one of a kind bike and ain't
another one on the road like it
with the where have you traveled you've
been around the country you've been
i've been to detroit chicago georgia
uh ohio cincinnati hamilton
ain't too many places around the south
east i haven't been you ever think about
leaving
well i've spent three fourths of my life
on the road
and i just grew tired of it how was it
hi how old are you 57 57.
and your health is good well not my
health ain't that good
i was diagnosed with cancer back about
uh almost five years ago what kind of
cancer brain cancer
brain cancer yeah and uh
you can't get nowhere nowhere around
here to get nowhere to go nowhere or do
nothing
i was supposed to went to a a cancer
center
didn't go so i picked me up a bible and
i'm doing things now that
i've never done before in my life i get
out of go
places things that i'd used to love to
do when i was growing up
that i don't even do anymore and
other than that so you did chemotherapy
anything like that
no how did you treat it
with the bible with the bible on these
two hands
i've moved let's see just my cousin down
there he had a place on his leg which
had moved right here
i moved to place off his chest
uh within 30 days it was gone
cousin had a blockage out here moved out
it's just with these hands
so drugs are a part of your life at one
point lord yeah i got hooked up on
i got on some uh i always had bad
headaches all my life
and uh one day i was going through
laurel county and i was going to stop
and get me some title now on the girl i
was with
she said here she said oh here's
something
said uh take it said it take care of
your headache
well 30 days later
after taking those two things i felt
like i could walk on
hour from then on that from 1992 on up i
was on drugs up to about four years ago
bad
cocaine peels drinking which i always
smoked a little pot
but other than that i tried meal twice
and i throwed it down i said no i don't
know that crap
and the one thing i never did do was get
to the needle
that's god's honest truth so what were
you telling me earlier about your family
something that happened my granddaughter
back when she was about three years old
she was brutally raped by somebody
and uh they never i don't know if they
ever did find out who downing
and i said all right another five or
find out who down that baby like that
that they never would do nobody else
that way
they never caught the guy i never didn't
have no if they did or not
is there a lot of crazy behavior here
crazy
look inside that house right there and
you'll see what i
see right there in bullet holes
that's where they mess around
every now and then you look out and look
out see who's around your house or
everything most people go to bed with
they lock their doors and everything i
sleep with mine open
so they know i ain't going to tolerate
the bull crap i'm telling you god's
honest truth
and then i hadn't found one day my
cousin came up missing
and when they found him he had been his
throat had been cut
he had been burnt uh
been strangled and
my cousin his daughter came out here
that day asked me would i help go find
him and i told her yeah
and last place my worst fears all my
life came true
and we've run up on her dad
back in that hollow and that was the
worst fear i'd ever felt in my life
i'm thinking i mean it didn't exactly
sink into at the time i seen him i
walked all the way around him
i didn't get exactly what it was you
know what i'm saying
but when it did dawn on me i started
doing pain pills
and when i when i did it i was running
up down this road here 70 and 80 miles
an hour
on a four-wheeler higher than a cat
didn't even know it
he's buried right up there they uh they
got the people that did it
but uh every time i look at that
it's to this day you know i forgot about
a lot of it
but to this day it really gets to you
seeing something like that
i've seen more deaths up and down the
highway right yonder
i've seen things you wouldn't believe on
that highway early of the morning
uh skeleton crossing the road
going to cross them and believe me i'm
telling you the god's honest truth
and some of the things that i've seen
you wouldn't believe me
uh that's the reason i kind of watch out
for this out through there overnight
because i've seen you don't never know
a little girl or sleeping in the room by
herself
you never know who's gonna be messing
around you'd be surprised some of the
people i've caught right out there in
that curve right behind that right
behind delamay's trailer
and they didn't know i was in a mile of
them overnight i get out and i walk
around because i can't hardly
wear smoke i can't hardly breathe
and i'm about to lay that down
you have good friends huh you have
friends very few anymore
but other than that nah i don't deal
with them no i don't hardly deal with
nobody no more i keep right to myself
what about your family you see your mom
right
i'm not too close with my family that's
the truth
but now i've got a lot of friends down
the road don't get me wrong i distant
myself from my old friends and i started
going i set myself on course and i made
myself a bunch of new friends
are you happy yeah
i'm happy as i've been in a long time
i'll sit around and talk about the
things i used to do and i
laughed you wouldn't believe
and some of the people i made i guess
are tickled i i swear
my tears roll right down my eyes i'm
telling you god's honest truth true
do you feel like you've lived the life
that you wanted to
well the way i see it i've lived
i've lived and dawned about most things
that only most men around this area
could
even dream about but the way i see it
have i lived my life to the fullest no i
don't think i have yet
and you're happy living here not here
i'm not but this part of the country
yeah this part of the count uh county
but i'm just not happy in curry branch
anymore
for one thing there's too much damage
these homes have been destroyed right
here you can't get no help to
do nothing yeah a lot of them are just
shacks huh a lot of them are just
they look at their phones wiped out yeah
i spent over 3 200 return inside that
trailer
ran out of funds
just lost it out
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in life
never trust nobody except yourself
always watch always listen and learn to
who's talking around you
and most of all if a woman goes out on
you one time get rid of her the next day
because she will do it again every time
all right mark and ray thank you so much
for talking with me man you're welcome
so glad we met appreciate it thank you
you